[Music]
what you're seeing here isn't a real
cockroach
it's actually a cleverly disguised date
a trick melissa mcsorely mastered for a
scene from crazy ex-girlfriend where a
character picks up a live cockroach and
eats it whole it's an opportunity to do
something that's out of the normal realm
for me and it gives me an opportunity to
start coming up with ways to tackle it
most props are meant to be picked up and
handled but some need to be consumed
that's where food stylists like melissa
come in and transform seaweed and chili
threads into cockroach legs and antennae
so how can she make everything from live
bugs to guts to blood edible
and do they actually taste good
the seaweed crunch right that's really
smart because that's going to make corn
chicken to crunch
food stylists are used to solve problems
like making sure ice cream doesn't melt
or finding a convincing substitute for
runny yolks when it comes to replicating
things one normally wouldn't eat melissa
has to use edible ingredients that
create the same look as the non-edible
prop
like blood typical fake human blood
isn't toxic and an actor can even have a
little around their mouth
but when melissa worked on true blood
she needed something safe enough for
vampire characters to drink in large
amounts
she started with a mix of cran cherry
and pomegranate juice great for scenes
where a glass or bottle was just sitting
out or being held but she also had to
replicate the true properties of blood
like its opaqueness which is why she
added wheatgrass to her formula and
there isn't just red food coloring in
there i had to add a little blue because
these juices were far more red than
blood would normally be so i just had to
tamp it down a little as a former
phlebotomist melissa knew that these
small details would add to the realism
so she also focused on the viscosity of
the blood if it was a scene where you
would see them pick up the glass and
drink and put it down you would want to
see the blood adhere to the side and
slowly go down to achieve this effect
she thickened her concoction with
methocellulus and then if someone were
to drink it
you can see that it will slide back down
the side of the glass
cheers
this is really good this is like yeah it
tastes just like a like really fine
juice because it's so thick if i was on
the true blood set they'd have to be
like stop drinking that drink something
else sometimes productions want an
edible prop even if the actors aren't
planning on eating it like this scene
from the amazon series homecoming these
two characters would be handling raw
chicken guts and other foods and objects
at the same time to avoid
cross-contamination on set melissa
created edible and safe chicken guts out
of carefully disguised food while
sausage casings made sense for the
intestines meat can easily go bad during
long shoot days so instead she filled
collagen casings with bean curd chicken
blood is also more yellow so she dyed
her ingredients yellow and then switched
to pink as the intestines grew pinker
the further down they go
it's important to use foods that can
take many different shapes and sizes for
example melissa would use ramen or glass
noodles here over spaghetti as they are
more pliable it takes on different
shapes than spaghetti does it also has
different edges to it where spaghetti is
like totally round this is probably more
like a linguine
then by dyeing these turnips different
colors they could stand in for both the
heart and the liver on top of all that
you can see cherry tomatoes and kumquats
this is the kind of detail that could
only come from the close eye of a food
stylist
so while i was doing my research i found
a few pictures of hens that actually had
unlaid eggs inside their cavity and they
basically look like a very very orange
organic egg yolk if melissa can't find a
specific food that can stand in for
something else she'll have to make her
edible props from scratch like in this
scene from the netflix series daybreak
where ms crumble eats a handful of live
maggots pulled from the trash in this
shot you see actual live mags who were
on set with the wrangler and had to be
kept safe so in this shot the maggot
actors were swapped for fake gummy
maggots
i mean i know they're fake but i mean
they look exactly like maggots so
there's a part of me that's just like
you know like especially like when i
look down the bowl you got a couple like
stuck to the side there
to get the correct form melissa started
off with a mold of plastic grubs that
she found at a bait and tackle store and
they were very very close in like size
and shape and they had the same ribbing
as a little maggot she filled the mold
with gelatin which made them naturally
wiggling more movement can be added
based on how you hold the bowl full of
them
oh like so it's just start discerning
literally so they kind of start
cascading down whatever even though they
were so tiny they couldn't be uniform in
color over the course of the life of a
maggot they change colors so when you
actually see the maggots in daybreak
you'll see that there's a range going
from translucent
to white and then leaning in towards a
beige and then to a brown
first she had a coconut pudding followed
by caramel coloring and almond milk to
make them darker as they aged wait
let me also act like i'm actually eating
maggots oh if i was like fear factor or
something
yeah this tastes great have you guys had
these
they like fruit snacks
the little details melissa had to get
right in each maggot pale in comparison
to the cockroach from crazy
ex-girlfriend edible props are
frequently shown in close-up form
meaning melissa couldn't get away with
using a date on its own it also needed
legs antennae wings and a head
chili threads replicated floppy and
tight and dry seaweed was sturdy enough
for its legs
as for the body melissa sorted through
an entire container of dates the first
thing that i look at is the size and to
make sure that it's not too big or too
small for the final cockroach the second
thing that i look for is that they're
not too wrinkled they're not too
shriveled some of them are too broken up
to actually use since the wings need to
be all one piece and look like they're
attached the reason that i picked these
three dates to start with is they're all
about the same uniform size and the
skins are perfectly intact this allowed
her to fillet and flatten the dates and
she noticed that roaches are typically
flatter than that of average dates so
taking out
as much of the meat in the back part of
the date as i can and then that leaves
the wings separate and hollow and then
the second date that we choose is the
one that i use for the head i usually
look for ones that have a little smaller
and pointed top and that are a little
bit darker than the actual cockroach
body we've chosen
meanwhile the natural stickiness of the
dates acted as a glue when piecing the
two together
making sure everything fit together was
by choosing the exact right pieces of
seaweed was so crucial it's just looking
for ones that have a slight curve
to it so that they can actually fit into
the body and leave the legs straight the
monotonous task of choosing the right
strands pay off on cam in the final shot
the flexible chili threads naturally
move with the wind like real antennae
would plus to add the crunch missing
from the date that's so nice i don't
want to ruin it but
to do it
[Music]
you see we
also gives it a surprise like
salty fishing stone so even that the
reaction was a bit uh authentic because
i was like why don't dates taste like
and then when i heard the salty fishy
taste of seaweed i'm like oh
it's these my new details that make the
most convincing edible props and get the
best reactions
for judy moody and the not bomber summer
melissa created edible pieces of
bigfoot's poop which the characters
accidentally eat using peanut butter and
chocolate for color and texture seems
obvious but there's more than meets the
eye the nuts are a nice touch well it's
not just poop it's bigfoot poop
so we have to assume bigfoot lives in
the woods yeah nuts and berries i
figured his poop would have been a
little bit bigger also would have
accepted corn
[Music]
oil
it's like a brownie it is a brownie
right kind of like
[Music]
mentally i'm just being like i'm still
like this looks a lot like poo poo poo
poo poo poo poop scoop in your mouth
stop what you're doing
this poop is fantastic